I can do this all day yeah I know test
here we go you can see Avengers in game
again nice and again it's baby he'll
grow and again somebody peed my pants
time travel oh my gosh my records across
the globe
part of the journey
[Music]
you stand
be a part of cinematic history assembled
of ventures and game now play it's
powerful being on set with these people
it's been almost a ten year journey I
couldn't imagine a better group of
people to be sharing this ride with
everyone was kind of swimming in the
same direction and before you know it it
was like it's kind of like like a crew
team everyone's everyone's rowing and
rhythm and the flying how are you guys
planning on beating that together
I have a really really deep sense of
gratitude and joy you trust me I do I
just saw a couple scenes from this film
cut together a rough cut and you get
choked up you know they're not even
emotional scenes but I was getting
choked up but it is because of this
journey
some people move on but not us
not us everybody is Charlie this is
gonna be my Captain America video
because it's Chris Evans birthday in
real lives
so say happy birthday to Captain America
and to talk about the future of the
Captain America character and Chris
Evans Steve Rogers character within the
Marvel Cinematic Universe because the
Russos did say a little while ago before
endgame came out that Chris Evans was
not done with Marvel and you would find
out what that means after you see
endgame so this is the clip of him
talking about that I think was more
emotional for him than us only because
you know he's not done yet so yeah and
and I won't explain what that means but
the audience will soon understand what
I'm talking since endgame has come out
we actually know what that means now so
I'll break everything down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
we're doing to give away for spider-man
far from home tickets - all you have to
do to enter that is just leave a comment
about spider-man or Captain America on
the video first thing though I love some
of the questions that he's answering
there like he doesn't have a full copy
of a Captain America costume he doesn't
say which one he wants to steal so I'm
assuming either the brand new comic book
looking scale armor or the classic
Avengers the original Avengers costume
because the Captain America Civil War
one was pretty cool and he said he kind
of hated the original Captain America
costume the very cloth looking one
during the First Avenger play ball with
us during that Captain America vs
Captain America fight if you guys didn't
know they did make subtle changes to his
helmet since the original Avengers movie
so the original version of the helmet
did this weird thing where it covered
his ears Chris Evans
said he hated it on set when they were
filming with it because he couldn't hear
anything that anybody was saying around
him he just made things way more
difficult than they needed to be so by
the time we got to Winter Soldier they
redesigned it so that it didn't cover
his ears anymore the other minor
differences you may have noticed between
older Captain America and younger
Captain America is as you can see all
the city miles on old Captain America
he's just wearier sadder
he even swears more you gotta be
[ __ ] me just because of all the crap
that he's been through since this
original Avengers movie
but the big stuff about the future of
Captain America I know this is the
important stuff what's gonna happen with
Chris Evans in the MCU if Captain
America is really old right now will
they ever tell the story of what
happened to Captain America after he
went back in time so this is all about
what the Russos were talking about when
they said the Chris Evans was not done
with Marvel after avengers endgame there
are a couple things that have been
confirmed and then there are a couple
things that are rumored that we'll
probably find out about role soon the
stuff we know that is happening is is
that he's coming back to direct episodes
of The Avengers spin-off shows during
Marvel phase four the Falcon Winter
Soldier series with Falcon taking up the
mantle of Captain America The Scarlet
Witch vision show the Loki show the
rumored Hawkeye showed that they haven't
absolutely confirmed yet but that we all
are pretty sure that they're making he's
even coming back for a Marvel what if
animated show to provide his voice for
Steve Rogers because it's animated so he
doesn't have to go on screen as Captain
America but the first episode they
revealed is going to be what if Steve
Rogers had gotten an Iron Man suit made
by Howard Stark and Peggy Carter had
gotten the Super Soldier Serum so Hayley
Atwell is also coming back to do the
voice of Peggy Carter for that episode
there are rumors that he might come back
to cameo a couple times as old Captain
America in future Avengers movies to
dole out a little bit of wisdom but
obviously he's gonna stay really old so
if he comes back as a young version of
Steve Rogers in a future Avengers movie
it would either be a secret war
situation where you have an alternate
reality
Captain America coming into our reality
or it's one of those Spiderman far from
home funny advertisements that they
played that he recorded a long time ago
like I'll look at this funny clip of
Captain America doing PSAs so he got to
tension the Russos in the writers have
also hinted that they might tell the
story of what happened to Captain
America after he went back in time to
return the stones because there's this
whole untold history and he just shows
up on the bench as a super old man like
what happened during all those missing
years when he was married to Peggy
Carter having those two children so cool
thing that the Russos and the writers
talked about is that if you remember the
Winter Soldier scene with old Peggy
Carter who was having memory problems
she would fade in and out recognize
steve-o
for a minute I remembered everything
that the secret husband that we never
learn
about that she had been married to once
was Steve Rogers and they just kept it
really quiet on the DL and her two
children were Steve Rogers children
it's just that in this scene our Captain
America hadn't experienced that yet so
obviously he didn't know anything about
he just assumed that she got married to
someone else and that every once in a
while when Peggy Carter would be lucid
and remember everything she would
remember that Steve Rogers was her
husband and she had a life with him Oh
for a minute I remembered everything but
then it would fade back out as her
memory problems would flare up they
claimed that they always intended to pay
it off that way but I think it's a bit
of a retroactive easter egg like saying
the little kid in Iron Man 2 wearing the
Iron Man mask was really Peter Parker
when they didn't quite plant it out that
way when Iron Man 2 was being made but
later on it just makes sense that it
would be Peter Parker so then later
Kevin Feige ratifies at his official
Canon yes that little kid was Peter
Parker before he became spider-man so
he's always been a Tony Stark fan but
beyond those projects that I mentioned
and maybe coming back once or twice as
old cap to give some advice to Falcons
new Captain America as he's trying to
take on the mantle I'm not expecting a
whole lot from him during phase four in
front of the camera most of Chris Evans
future with Marvel in the next say like
three to four years is gonna be behind
the camera but the really cool thing is
is that Chris Evans is a total dude and
he is totally happy to do funny promos
so it's always possible that he puts
back on the Captain America suit for a
really quick promo sometimes it leads to
very little and it seems like it's not
worth it and you wonder why you waited
so long for something so disappointing
this is that clip of Chris Evans though
talking about his last day on set at the
big Comic Con panel a little while ago I
think well it was aligned I think it was
aligned to
no he was overwhelmed with emotion well
it was you know it was rishu so you
doing these little picks and pops and
it's these little it's it's it's it's
it's just little things that they need
it might have been aligned to Paul Rudd
he wasn't there but it was a stupid Ally
and the line wasn't memorable to me the
day was more memorable than the line now
because we've seen in-game we actually
know what he's talking about when he
said all those things let me know in the
comments though big question for you
guys where do you want Captain America
Steve Rogers to pop back up again in the
MCU if it's not gonna be for another
three or four years this summer Marvel
is supposed to have a really big
comic-con panel we'll probably get a
phase four schedule if we don't get it
there then we'll get it at d23 but most
of the trailers and the teasers for the
Disney Plus streaming service will drop
at d23 so of course I'll do videos for
all that stuff but the Avengers end game
blu-ray is gonna drop right after Comic
Con so we'll get a whole bunch more
deleted scenes and bonus features so
I'll break that stuff down too but leave
all your requests in the comments below
while you wait for everything you can
click here for that brand new spider-man
far from home trailer and you can click
here for all my Avengers and game Easter
eggs thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome i'll see you guys